here's a few of them that I've made some
notes on that you would only see if you
were to indulge and spend time with
these guys um 2014 was when I started
the channel a few years into the channel
somebody said to me Rich you should do a
video on the kind of women not to date
they really liked my content they
thought my advice uh that I was
dispensing was good and they wanted to
hear an opinion on um I guess red flags
women um so I made a video on that and
it blew up and then I got sucked into um
the manosphere I didn't know what the
hell the manosphere was it sounded like
a gay nightclub to me um there's
apparently a president of the manosphere
that nobody elected uh which is also
another problem as well he's he's a bit
of a weirdo um but there's a whole bunch
of stuff beyond that so here's a few
notes that I have uh guys will claim
that their dating system allows them to
only date gorgeous women but are
revealed to be in a relationship with an
average at best woman many of them older
than the guys and even single mothers
another one uh many have criminal
records and in some cases have been
forced to move and flee their home
country are running from the law another
one uh claiming to be a
multi-millionaire with several
successful businesses only to be
discovered to be living at home with
family completely broke yes I was at his
house and I saw it
firsthand uh have a sorry have gotten
socially awkward men incarcerated for
following their dating systems and
techniques you can go look this up on
Google there's several articles and
video footage of uh socially awkward
maybe even autistic guys on the Spectrum
uh in trial and the pickup artists that
sold them the course and the cold
approach stuff is nowhere to be seen
because they flee the country um so
there's let's just keep going let's keep
going right um warns you against
inviting single mothers into your life
then lies about marrying one and
covertly invites a single mother into
their own life which by the way was also
older than him there's a lot of drama
around all of these things you know a
lot a lot of the infighting another one
uh says there a a worldclass pickup
artist that can teach you to seduce and
sleep with beautiful women is exposed
for hiring prostitutes to be paid actors
in their boot camps so these are pickup
artists uh usually in uh large cities
they hold these boot camps um paid
actors in boot camps to be seduced and
sleep with these paying students now in
many cases the pickup artists will even
sleep with the prostitutes prior to
placing them for the students to sleep
with so they scratch their itch first so
they their own students that they're
paying for to learn skills to seduce who
are usually socially awkward dorks or
nerds that that haven't leveled up their
life they haven't gotten the seven
spokes of a high value man that I talk
about in the chapter in my book uh in
the updated version that's the second
edition only um they get them in a
scenario where they pay thousands of
dollars to come out to I don't know a
vent or a city and then these puas will
hire prostitutes bang them first and
then give their sloppy seconds to these
guys in these events again this is all
factual uh another one tells you to do
the work lift weights eat clean go get
some restful sleep but we stay up the
entire night get lapos suction to remove
belly fat because they're too lazy to do
the work themselves relentlessly going
on about how to have a strong frame in a
long-term relationship I spent an entire
weekend with this guy and how important
it is it'll s he'll sell advice on how
to do it yet is revealed during that
weekend to have no frame in his own
relationship and his girlfriend at that
time capitalized his time with excessive
drama into perpetuity that
weekend uh another one says to have an
amazing bisexual girlfriend that is
compliant loving and brings other women
into the bedroom for threesome yet has
been exposed to have an abusive
girlfriend that physically assaults and
batters him I saw the text exchanges on
this one tells men never to listen to
the dating advice of female dating
coaches if you go back in the manosphere
uh 2017 18 1920 in and around then um
there was a lot of uh uniform
conversations around you know it's a man
space so let's keep it that way and they
would say you know don't work with
female dating coaches don't take the
advice of women and dating coaches and
now many of them today work with these
female dating coaches another one tells
men they are legends for betting sorry
tells men that they themselves are
legends for betting thousand plus
beautiful women then they'll admit that
some of these women that they had sex
with were transsexuals and born as
biological
men and one of my favorites and I'll get
to the last two in a second is calls men
that sends money simps to only fans
women yet it was found out that the
manager of an only fans
agency is getting money for his girls
from the same guy that calls these only
fans uh guys you know subscribers simps
I could not believe it when I saw this
one there was literally a tweet calling
these guys simps and then the manager of
these only fans girls you can take a
guess who it might be uh sent me a
screenshot of this guy's email with his
name in the email it was clearly him
making a monthly subscription payments
to his only fans agency to one of his
girls and let's not forget about the uh
[__] that was unable to cloth or a
girl rejected him in a nightclub and he
took the glass that he was drinking his
beverage from and smash it into her
face I could keep going there's many
many more guys the point being is the
stuff that the um that the uh the
Christian pill guys are criticizing the
red pill in a manosphere for um like
just a that's just a tip of the iceberg
and there's a significant PR issue that
the manosphere and you know the red pill
itself deals with today as a consequence
of that I really hope you guys enjoyed
that clip if you want to watch the full
length podcast you can find that over
here that clip's from if you're new to
the channel make sure you hit subscribe
over here and pin down below in the top
comment you'll find a bunch of useful
links to my website my supplement line
books and a bunch of other stuff have an
amazing day peace out